long before love story there were many
other highly romantic stories on the
screen camille rubbering heights love
affair and maybe one of the greatest of
them all seventh heaven at the first
Academy Awards presentation in 1929
three of the Oscars went to seventh
heaven tonight we have with us one of
the stars of that picture the first
actress to win an Academy Award miss
Janet Gaynor
the set where I made most of my pictures
is now Century City and the bean fields
I used to pass on Wilshire Boulevard
going to work are now high-rise
apartments but the pictures themselves
are still being shown to film students
today pictures directed by such talented
men as Frank boys Aggie FW Murnau and
Raoul Walsh this year's the nominees for
best achievement in directing are
Federico Fellini for Fellini Satyricon
Arthur Hiller for love story Robert
Altman for mash Franklin J Schaffner for
a party 10 Russell for women in love did
you do the anima Skinner thank you the
winner is Franklin James Shatner for mr.
Shatner will be followed
who portrayed general homer and Bradley
in the film
Shafi were here tonight he would say
that it's an honor to accept this award
I know he would thank you for it but
since he isn't thank you
but since he isn't here let me say that
you couldn't have given it to a better
fella he deserves it I know I was there